ja wir sind in san francisco bei pixar
immer noch und meine erste frage ist
nicht hartings going sondern wie ist die
lage denn sascha kann deutsch weil ich
aus deutschland kommen ok wie kommt man
dann nach pixar oder zu pixar
mich hat ich habe in deutschland die
animation vorgearbeitet ich hatte
nachdem ich abschluss gemacht hat denn
an der filmakademie in ludwigsburg
mit ein paar folgten studio gegründet
studio soi und da hatte ich für fünf
jahre mit meinen freunden gearbeitet und
dann wie gesagt hat mich die wanderlust
gepackt und ich fragte mich wie ich da
draußen denn so ist und wie bewirbt man
sich hier ich habe mehrere beworben
online über die website da wir sind die
jobs muss sogar so sein weil die da sehr
korrekt sind über den weg wo man sich
bewirbt das ist nicht über irgendwelche
kontakte funktioniert sondern wirklich
dass alle die gleiche chance haben und
da hab ich mich beworben und dann haben
sie mich für ein telefon interview
angefragt und es gab abend sein telefon
radio und da haben sie mich eingeflogen
für ein interview hier und dann ein paar
wochen später haben sie sich mich
gefragt ob ich den job will ok was muss
man können um den job zu kriegen und
abgefragt also in meinem fall da ich da
ich sehr viel mit kamera arbeit zu tun
hat war es abgesehen davon dass ich
gezeigt habe ich zuvor gemacht hatte
ging es auch darum was für fotografen
ich mag also sehr viel um das generelle
interesse am filmemachen einfach und an
der fotografie und und einfach an am
künstlerischen interesse was man
außerhalb von pixar hat das schalten wir
auch wenn man hier hinten sieht dann
sieht man an der wand das spielt eine
wichtige rolle was vom geschmack man
habe da lässt man sich auch von
inspirieren ich sehe er fotos von bernd
und hilla becher
fotografen aus düsseldorf dass das wird
abgefragt also es ist nicht ein muss
aber
animation ist so ein bereich der mann
man die inspiration die man kriegt es
ist immer komisch wenn man es nur aus
anderen animationsfilmen nimmt deswegen
wird sehr viel wird aus der fotografie
genommen oder von der malerei und
wirklich von anderen medien die
existieren und wo sehr gute leute eine
sehr schöne sachen machen und deswegen
ist es eigentlich sehr
hilfreich wenn man
offen kopf hat einfach komplett andere
sachen ob für theater oder europa oder
was auch immer ist das in der ganzen
branche so oder ist der blick sascha
ausnahme es ist schon in der ganzen
branche so ich habe mich jetzt nicht bei
vielen anderen firmen beworben aber ich
weiß das ist überall selbst bei kleinen
und bei großen firmen geht es immer
darum wie wie fasziniert ist man von dem
gebiet und wo kommen die einflüsse von
einem heer aber dann hast du dich hier
beworben nicht woanders ich habe mich
auch woanders nicht wahr sein ich wollte
amerika oder kanada und hab da so ein
rund trip gemacht wo ich mir die städte
angeguckt habe und die firmen angeguckt
dabei mir gesagt papa kann ich hallo
sagen oder vorbeigucken weil der stadt
für mich auch sehr wichtig ist dass ich
der markt wo ich wohne und
pixar wurde es dann weil ich mag die
filme von pixar halt am liebsten
deswegen ist im endeffekt besser
geworden und nicht irgendeine andere
firma wie wo auch super leute sind und
sind sehr schönen städten aber san
francisco mochte ich fast am liebsten
als stadt abgesehen von new york
und deswegen wurde das hier halt ok
warum mag die filme vom pc sitzen
ich finde sie sind sie haben irgendwie
eine sind ehrlich ich finde sie sind
sehr sehr
sie sind sehr positiv und sie sind sehr
ehrlich in dem was sie sagen wollen sie
haben nicht viel zu tun mit
irgendwelchen magix hier schaut mal hier
hin ganz viel unterhaltung und danach
vergisst man sie sondern haben nicht der
starke seele öffentlich immer von der
geschichte her und das hast du auch als
du hier war es gespürt
ja ich muss sagen das erste als ich hier
war war ich erstaunt weil die atmosphäre
so entspannt ist gerade im vergleich zu
europa ganz viele firmen auch gerade in
form effekte bereich her größere firmen
geht man rein und man merkt wie alle
gestresst sind und viel zu tun haben und
es ist so ein bisschen
depressiv halt und ich war hier
wahnsinnig erstaunlich brief rhein in
dieses große stürmer am anfang und die
leute schienen glücklich und waren
entspannt und nicht gestresst also klar
ist stress in der arbeit aber es ist
sehr angenehm weil als basis ist das
alles sehr entspannt und freundlich und
klar
da hat man irgendwann viel zu tun aber
das baut dann nicht auf eine
grundstimmung von stress okay das ist
schon mal gut haben du bist aber jetzt
mit cars 2 fertig das heißt jetzt ist
etwas entspannung oder ist dann das
nächste projekt schon dran es ist schon
das nächste folgt ich bin mit chaos
schon seit
vier monaten oder so ähnlich
und genau jetzt ist das nächste projekt
wave kann das nicht herauskommen das
zeigt uns aber nicht sondern du kannst
uns aber zeigen wie das aussieht wie
kannst du wenn du da du bist ja quasi
kameramann genau wie du bist kameramann
wie das aussieht wenn du eine kamera für
genau ich habe leider nicht die software
direkt auf machen weil wir jetzt eine
neuere version schon haben es ist dann
schwierig die alten sachen aufzubringen
aber ich kann kurz was zeigen und zwar
was wir in der kamera abteilung bekommen
ist sind storyboards das heißt
also so etwas wie das hier was
gezeichnet ist
wo klar ist okay was passiert ist das
auto fliegt auf den kran und springt vom
kran ab auf dieses gebäude was daneben
ist und eigentlich sind hier ja schon
kameraeinstellungen festgelegt zum
gewissen rahmen oder wie die kamera ist
wenn er auf kommt die aber
wahrscheinlich nicht immer
hundertprozentig stimmen genau das ist
das zeichnen ist muss irgendeine kamera
existieren die können ja nicht was
zeigen ohne eine kameraeinstellung zu
haben aber was wir dann zum beispiel
machen im layout und in dem fall war das
was ich gemacht habe ist wir bauen das
alles in 3d nach mit einem 3d kann und
es sieht nicht so schön aus wie es am
ende aussieht aber wir haben alle die
figuren die proportionen stimmen ganz
oft stimmen die proportionen beim story
hinein
und dann bauen wir einfach ganz viele
verschiedene möglichkeit wie man das
film könnte wie es vielleicht
dramatischer sein kann das heißt jetzt
das ist eine weitere einstellung drauf
und jetzt kommen gleich ganz viel
dynamischere einstellungen mit dem auto
zum beispiel wir an der kamera vorbei
fliegt am drive und vielleicht oder wir
auf den kran drauf springt ein bisschen
weitere einstellungen
nur eine single auf den kran oder hier
alles in einem zusammen gedreht
auf dem kran die kamera haben während er
sich dreht mit dem auto hochgehen und im
endeffekt habe ich ganz am anfang einmal
das komplette nachgebaut und dann
überlege ich okay wie wer seine kamera
da oben ist wo das auto am ende
abspringt und ich drehe die kamera
einfach mit rüber oder eine kamera ist
schon da am ende
springt so ab und wir haben ja noch
helikopter hinaus
es kommt darauf an wenn section es so
wie hier dann relativ viel wenn es nur
noch unterhaltung ist hat man genauso
viel wie im storyboard vielleicht macht
man eine weitere einstellung und aber
bei sowas da ganz viele schnitte
passieren werden und da hier viel mehr
möglichkeiten sind wahrscheinlich
zehnmal soviel dem storyboard sind und
dass schicken wir dann zum schnitt und
die schneiden sich so was zusammen wie
sie es am besten haben wollen auch immer
mit feedback vom regisseur und dann
kriegen wir
den schnitt zurück und machen leichte
anpassung weil dann wissen wir welche
shots aufeinander folgen dann manchmal
passt man dann leicht sachen an wir
bauen hier auch alles langen das heißt
die chance die ich hier bauen sind nicht
genauso lang wie sie im film sein
könnten sondern ich krise zusagen von
viel früher bis viel später ok und im
schnitt können sie mal gucken wie viel
wollen sie von dem schotten haben einen
3d film welche einstellungen braucht man
dann bevorzugt weil es sind ja auch
szenerien die total neue serien bekannt
muss man da öfter mal eine totale haben
um das ganze zu zeigen oder arbeitet die
auch lieber mit namen details und so
weiter um normalisieren es hängt sehr
viel immer vom regisseur also es gibt
einmal den director of photography das
ist sozusagen pro film der hauptkamera
mann und dann hat den regisseur und
unterschiedliche leute haben
unterschiedliche geschmäcker aber was
wichtig ist ist dass man weiß wo man
denn gerade ist und deswegen gibt es
meistens am anfang eine einführende
totale einstellung vom ganzen set oder
ein bisschen später nach 34 shots
weshalb man muss das wichtigste ist
immer egal was man macht wie dynamisch
mann ist wie viel man die kamera bewegt
bis man weiß was passiert und wo es
passt gerade bei so was jetzt hier der
kran also passieren ja so viel eher
ungewöhnlich wie er über der szenerie
hängt an vier seilen da muss man ja
wahrscheinlich noch relativ oft was
total aus rein schneiden weil sonst ist
man ja ganz schnell genau so schlecht
versteht man nicht mal spazieren können
ja und es macht ihr spaß das macht mir
sehr viel spaß wie lange willst du bist
jetzt schon drei jahre hier fast drei
jahre im oktober sind die langen sitzen
bleiben ich weiß nicht vorher ist bleibt
vorerst bleibe ich aber ich habe nie ich
mache jetzt keinen plan für die nächsten
fünf jahre ich weiß jetzt gerade sehr
gerne mag und hier bleibe aber was in
fünf jahren passierte nicht super du
kannst mir den job empfehlen ich kann
den job empfehlen obwohl ich dazu sagen
muss ich habe da vorher bei studio soi
war ich fünf jahre und es ist ein sehr
andere art von arbeit und mir macht
beides spaß und sind zwei sehr
unterschiedliche dinge also in einer
großen firma ist was sehr sehr anderes
als in der kleinen firma und es ist
nicht dass das eine oder das andere
besser ist und mir persönlich fällt es
beide sehr sehr gut ich habe bloß für
fünf jahre von der kleinen firma
gearbeitet deswegen hat mich
interessiert wie es denn der großen
firma aber ich glaube nicht dass eine
große firma für jeden das richtige ist
genauso wie eine kleine firma nicht für
jeden das richtige aber heute hat alles
gepasst ich mag beides aber ich glaube
ich mag alles gut geht aber 3d animation
als beruf kannst du empfehlen aber wenn
ich höre ludwigsburg nur ganz kurze sind
hohe hürden navi muss man haben man muss
eben auch eine begabung haben muss ja
etwas einreichen aber wenn man es einmal
geschafft hat ist es hat ist es ein
super job mir ich mir hat die ausbildung
spaß gemacht und mir die arbeit danach
bisher immer spaß gemacht super danke
ich dir vielmals ja das war also jetzt
mal eine kleine berufsberatung hierbei
fix und wird vielleicht öfter mal geben